Das war's für heute!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal!
Das war's für heute!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal!
Das war's für heute!
mein mein agila ist kaputt also ich mein er fährt noch aber ich weiß nicht mal wie lange
und also für all dies nicht wissen ich habe ja ein
ich habe dieses ding hier in grün das ist quasi ein auto das ist jetzt irgendwie 20 jahre alt
oder so zumindest das hat jetzt hat jetzt endlich ich fahre nicht viel also wisst ihr ich bin ja
im prinzip so gut wie nie unterwegs und also im auto und der hat jetzt in letzter zeit schon
öfters probleme gehabt also angefangen von dass das ein licht beim zurückfahren nicht funktioniert
auf der einen seite dann was war letztens ich habe schon wieder ganz vergessen aber letztens
noch mal letztes ging er genau letztes ging ihm nicht richtig an und jetzt war das die system
für das wir wenn sie das kühlmittel kühlsystem undicht und das ding hat immer mehr das ist das
ist komplett komplett am abkacken genau so und ich dachte mir jetzt weißt du was easy kommen es
wird mal zeit du musst du musst dir immer neues auto kaufen also habe ich mal nach kleinen elektro
autos geguckt und da bin ich dann auf dieses ding gekommen das passt eigentlich ganz gut von
größe ausstattung und das was ich machen will allerdings kostet das halt ohne prämie viel zu
viel da das ist das kostet irgendwas in der in der größeren ausstattung kostet das in 39.000 euro
und das sehe ich nicht ein für neues auto auszugeben ich meine ich gebe ungern geld aus das
wisst ihr ja deswegen habe ich wahrscheinlich auch genug weil wenn man nichts ausgibt da irgendwie
sammelt sich halt an ich meine es ist nicht so dass ich mir das nicht leisten können 39.000
euro auszugeben für ein auto ich will keine 39.000 euro ausgeben also ich will keine 39.000 euro
ausgeben für ein auto so und es gibt so und es gibt noch bis nächstes jahr gibt es noch eine
eine förder innovations umwelt prämie fragt mich nicht wie das genau heißt und da kriegt man bis zu
9.000 euro quasi obendrauf also sprich irgendwie 3000 3000 euro vom hersteller und irgendwie 6000
euro die man noch mal beantragen kann der haken dabei ist der haken dabei ist wenn ihr euch jetzt
oder wenn ich mir jetzt ein elektroauto bestelle dann dauert das damit leasing ist hast du wieder
andere probleme da musst du dir dann über jede jeden huppel den erfährst gedanken machen oder
über jede jede noch so kleine hauch einer einer eines kratzer gedanken machen dass es am ende nicht
alles drauf bezahlen darfst und das übernehmen am ende ist auch nicht so billig das muss man
wirklich genau rechnen ob sich das lohnt zumindest aktuell kriegst du 9.000 euro prämie für ein
neues elektroauto was ziemlich gutes ich gehe mal davon aus wenn das laut hersteller 39.000
euro kostet in der gescheiten ausstattung und man ein bisschen mit dem händler labert wahrscheinlich
kriegt man es dann auch ein bisschen billiger plus minus die 9.000 euro prämie dann was weiß ich dann
wahrscheinlich unter 30.000 euro und das wäre ok das würde ich das würde ich ausgeben dafür
aber nicht so einfach in deutschland weil diese prämie die du beantragen kannst also die 9.000
euro prämie die du bei neuen elektroautos beantragen kannst die gilt plus noch bis ende des jahres und
du kannst diese prämie beantragen erst wenn du das auto zugelassen hast also nicht wenn du das
verbindlich bestellt sondern wenn du das angemeldet hast und wenn du das den antrag eingereicht hast
also es reicht nicht wenn du es einfach nur bestellt dieses jahr so und ab nächstem jahr
ich habe irgendwo auch ein video zu aufgemacht weil ich mir das noch mal genauer anhören wollte
so und nächstes jahr sinkt das ordentlich dann ist es irgendwie nur noch die hälfte dann ist
irgendwie nur 4.500 oder so anstatt 6.000 anstatt 9.000 und das ist halt echt ziemlich für den
arsch deswegen ist die sache die ich habe jetzt mal rumgeguckt und man kann bei fiat auf der
seite suchen nach händler die welche haben allerdings sehen das dann halt keine die man
sich komplett selbst zusammenstellen kann also sprich wenn du jetzt ein auto kaufen willst wo
du sagst ich will dieses paket haben ich will was was ich diese felgen haben ich will das haben
diese farbe haben dann müssen die das ja extra bestellen für dich anmelden geht aber muss halt
die karre haben jetzt ist ja das problem versuch versucht die karre zu bekommen so wobei ich jetzt
gerade bin jetzt gerade stehen geblieben na dann müssen die das bestellen aus italien oder wo
immer das gebaut wird die sache ist jetzt halt die manchmal haben händler noch autos da die
halt fertig sind ja ich weiß nicht wo die herkommen ob die irgendjemand nicht abgeholt hat oder so
aber ich habe jetzt über über die fiat webseite mal geguckt und so viele gibt es da nicht ja
letztendlich ist mir die farbe egal das paket ist mir jetzt auch nicht so wichtig was es ist
ja mal gucken also ich ich kann insofern nur ich kann es dir die dinger sind echt klein du
weißt was ich aktuell habe oder und ich finde das gut dass das so klein ist die abmaße von
dem fiat sind ungefähr mehr oder weniger genauso groß wie mein alter also das ein paar zentimeter
das nimmt sich nichts ich glaube breit sind sogar exakt gleich breit so ich ich ich will ja ja wir
machen demnächst was mit avalon ja ja da bin ich mal gespannt also wenn ich dieses jahr noch die
chance habe einzukriegen und auch so sagen wir mal so in einem zeitraum dass ich das mit dem
antrag und so noch machen kann und die förderung krieg dann würde ich mir ein elektroauto tatsächlich
kaufen und zwar den und wenn das dieses jahr nicht mehr funktioniert wenn es da keine chance
gibt da kaufe ich mir kein elektroauto weil wie gesagt ich würde mir prinzipiell ganz gern eins
kaufen da muss ich nicht mehr tanken fahren und für meine mini strecken die ich fahre ist das ist
das wunderbar aber wenn auch ein bisschen teuer muss sagen sie wirklich rechnen tut sich das
ganze jahr irgendwo nicht aber trotzdem dann würde ich das machen aber nächstes jahr würde ich
nicht mehr machen also ich gebe halt ungern geld aus und vor allem unsinnig geld aus bin ich mal
gespannt die neu ist es ist es 11 ist es ist das 11 avalon ja nicht ein paar tagen rausgekommen habe
ich irgendwo was auf reddit gelesen dass das angeblich jetzt raus ist oder ist das eine
ankündigung dass es demnächst rauskommt ja da bin ich nämlich interessant darauf damit kannst du
jetzt angeblich auch android und ios anwendungen und und firefox web os anwendung und alle möglichen
geschäft machen ja ich werde auf jeden fall die neueste version ausprobieren ich habe
gerade mal geguckt was das ist das ist so ein riesen tractor ich habe keine ahnung was die
machen wahrscheinlich ist es unter der haube einen browser oder so zweifelsfall sind die
meisten mobile anwendungen heute browser ja ich bin mal gespannt ob das klappt dieses
jahr mit electroauto wie gesagt wenn nicht dann nicht und da kaufe ich mir keins weil
wie gesagt 40.000 euro gebe ich dafür nicht aus so ein bisschen unter 30.000 mit förderung ist
ok aber 40.000 euro gebe ich dafür nicht aus moin ab und zu funktionieren einfach alle weiter
mit das problem ist mir nicht bekannt das kenne ich nicht also bei mir funktioniert die erweitern
immer ich glaube ihr habt noch nicht ein stream gesehen wo ich chrome aufgemacht hab und da ging
die erweitern ich muss ich ein stückchen leiser so der graf alexander abs als subscribt massive
subscription möb auch dankeschön leute hier captain pengen poggers ist auch wieder am start
ob chrome da neu installieren hilft vielleicht hast du das problem dass du erweiterungen installierst
die da die google aus dem shop nimmt weil sie irgendwelche dubiosen sachen enthalten keine
ahnung ich bekomme was ja ich bekomme die hälfte das lohnt sich nicht wirklich zu
subscriben das also natürlich unterm strich für mich schon aber von dem anteil her lohnt
sich irgendwie nicht wirklich wenn sich überlegt eigentlich eigentlich bezahlt sich besaß
mit prime subs ja selbst zur hälfte oder besser gesagt er muss ja eigentlich hat das
geld ja schon ne eigentlich lohnt sich doch prime subs ich leute ich ich ich ziehe das
zurück was ich gesagt habe und behaupte das gegenteil natürlich lohnt sich weil er hat
ja das geld schon und jetzt muss ein bisschen was rausrücken also ist gut alle prime suppen
die können poc aber ich freue mich auch dass ihr da seid muss sich keiner hier irgendwelche
subs aus den fingern saugen es sei denn ihr habt prime subs offen und wisst nicht wohin
dann freue ich mich natürlich drüber der hype trainer mal gucken ob wir den schaffen
wir hatten letztens mal hype train hype train level 5 der dann bei 100 prozent war und irgendwie
auch durchgelaufen ist und uns richtig gebatet hat weil er einfach nicht aufgehört hat bei
100 prozent oder beim am ende der zeit irgendwie ganz komisch pfeife aber das kannst du nur
maximal fünf familienmitglieder haben oder kann man aber kann man im amazon familien account
auch wieder leute ausladen so meine familie wechselt hat einmal im monat wir wollen uns
ja hier keine amazons kamas geschichten angucken ja ja so viel zu meinem elektro elektroauto
suchen nicht so einfach wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe alles das nächste was ich gesehen habe
bevor wir uns ein paar videos angucken das nächste was ich gesehen habe ist wahrscheinlich
habt ihr die meldung auch gesehen es gab hierbei ich beheise aber hier google dedos ja es gab
ja wieder einen riesen dedos angriff auf google die im prinzip wo ist der link zu dem offiziellen
google blog post die eigentlich mittlerweile nur noch als schwanzvergleich von den cloud
anbieter benutzt werden achtung leute flash bang also mittlerweile gibt es ja total viele
dieser blog post microsoft macht solche blog post wir haben den größten dedos angriff
aller zeiten abgewehrt cloudflare macht solche blog post wir haben den größten dedos angriff
aller zeiten abgewehrt und jetzt kommt google um die ecke übrigens wir haben auch den größten
dedos angriff aller zeiten abgewehrt und wenn man das mal vergleicht die die überschlagen
sich die überschlagen sich ja alle glaube ich dass cloudflare postet den gleichen den
gleichen krempel ja in dem fall bei microsoft die haben was zum größten teil von es war
anfang des jahres microsoft hat zum größten teil was über udp traffic geschrieben google
schreibt jetzt was über layer 7 dedos angriff aber was ich eigentlich ganz interessant
finde ist wenn man sich mal anguckt was für ausmaße das mittlerweile annimmt das ist
schon nicht ohne also da muss man echt sagen da da geht was aber wie gesagt also diese
ganzen blog post ist ja alles immer ziemlich erschwanz vergesst cloudflare äh was was
ist die schreiben genau das gleiche in ihrem blog ja guck hier die schreiben die schreiben
genau das gleiche größte den aus aller zeiten bla bla bla also im prinzip nimmt sich da
microsoft google cloudflare amazon und und wenn es auch alles gibt dann nicht viel aber
ich finde es in dem fall ganz interessant was sie was sie so schreiben was ich wollte
neulich die prüfungsordnung von der iak und da sind die mona die seite mit mona von bsi
untersucht die hatten wohl auch das wundert mich bei der iak nicht die iak ist ein riesen
unfähiger haufen an unfähigen leuten ja also wie gesagt die haben es auch geschafft mein
abschlussprojekt zu verlieren und dann zu sagen ich hätte es nicht eingereicht also
ich den den traue ich wirklich alles zu mulfs moin also iak ist iak ich habe überlegt ob
ich dazu nicht ein video machen soll weil es gibt ein paar ganz interessante sachen
was man dazu erzählen kann zu zu diesem bericht ich mein wie gesagt zu 90 prozent ist es werbung
wie geil google diesen dedos angriff hier wieder vereitelt hat aber ich finde es sind
ein paar ganz interessante geschichten dabei vielleicht habt ihr die meldung auch gesehen
vor ein paar tagen auf newsseiten wie gesagt bei heise stets auf den stets in den news
uns und bei golem scheint glaube ich auch und bei englischsprachigen seiten und so gab
es das gab es gab es das auch alles das hier google wieder irgendwie krasse krasse dedos
hacker mans abgewehrt hat zumindest gibt es paar sachen ich kann es kann es ganz spannend
daran finden zum beispiel zum beispiel was ich ganz spannend dran finde wenn man das
mal vergleicht das was microsoft schreibt und das was google schreibt dass die beide
was schreiben von größte dedos attacke aller zeiten aber es sich eigentlich auf komplett
unterschiedliche unterschiedliche sachen bezieht bei google geht es um 46 millionen
requests pro sekunde und bei microsoft geht es um udp traffic und packages pro sekunde
also bei microsoft geht es um 3,47 terabit pro sekunde und um 340 millionen packages
pro sekunde was man daran sieht ist dass requests und packages sich zwar ähnlich anhören aber
was ziemlich unterschiedliche sind weil das sieht man ja schon in größten ordnung hier
ist das größte 46 millionen requests und hier ist das größte 360 irgendwie was 340
millionen packages ist ja auch logisch hier geht es ja auch um udp traffic und hier geht
es um layer sieben traffic wobei man halt sagen muss layer sieben traffic also layer sieben
ist immer so ein bisschen schwammig irgendwie zumindest bei den ganzen dedos geschichten
wo microsoft drüber geschrieben hat ging es ja darum das netzwerk möglichst schnell
dicht zu machen und hier ging es darum möglichst viel traffic zu generieren und ja nach möglichkeit
auch last auf den system zu generieren und das möglichst nachhaltig kaputt zu machen
letztendlich geht es bei beidem halt rum irgendwas auf den weg kaputt zu machen dass
der service nicht mehr erreichbar ist aber bei microsoft ging es hauptsächlich darum
die netzwerk infrastruktur dicht zu machen mit udp traffic und massig bandbreite und
hier ging es darum ja auch massig bandbreite zu verursachen aber die systeme irgendwie
anzugreifen und abzuschießen ist ja was anderes das ist ja auch ein layer sieben dedos wer
hat aufgepasst was ist layer sieben im osi modell leute wer hat aufgepasst ich mein
es ist eh ziemlich schwammig das betrifft ein layer sieben angriff betrifft natürlich
auch alle schichten unten drunter und es lässt sich eh nicht so ganz klar abgrenzen layer
acht wissen wir layer acht sind wir die vom bildschirm setzen ich mein es gibt ja es
gibt ja verschiedenste application korrekt genau deswegen ist das hier deswegen ist das
hier ein application layer dedos oder so könnte man auch sagen aber das ist alles das ist
alles irgendwie ein bisschen ein bisschen schwammig du willst es gibt ja verschiedenste angriff
szenarien was so was angeht ich label jetzt einfach ein bisschen mal so vor mich hin
bevor wir uns mal videos angucken weil ich das thema gerade im vergleich relativ relativ
spannend finde anwendung ja richtig also es gibt gibt ja verschiedenste angriff szenarien
also du hast solche sachen so die klassiker nenne ich jetzt mal sowas wo du hier beispielsweise
traffic verursachen kannst wo sich microsoft drauf bezogen hat du hast du die klassiker
du hast sowas wie dns amplification oder ntp amplification weiß gar nicht ob es dazu
schöne bilder gibt dass das sie doch ok das ist das ist ein ziemlich hässliches bild
aber ich glaube da erkennt man eigentlich ganz gut woran es darum geht also zumindest
sowas wie dns amplification war in der vergangenheit relativ beliebt warum weil du selbst als angreifer
nicht viel machen musst du schickst an ein dns server anfragen und fälscht die absender
adresse so und dann antwortet der dns server also du besetzt die absender adresse das jenigen
allen den du angreifen willst und dann schickst du das mit der gefälschten absender adresse
an den dns server und der dns server antwortet dann demjenigen den du angreifen willst der
eigentlich gar nicht angefragt hat und wenn du das ganz oft machst an ganz viele dns
server ist es für dich relativ geringer aufwand dns anfragen rauszuschicken steht ja auch
hier eine 60 byte lange anfrage kann in bestimmten fällen eine 300 byte lange antwort provozieren
also sprich du passt selbst relativ wenig aufwand und kannst ordentlich traffic verursachen
das ist ntp ntp amplifier x relativ ähnlich da machst du es mit ntp anfragen so das war
so in der vergangenheit relativ beliebt aber das ist in letzter zeit in letzter zeit ist
das ein bisschen außer mode gekommen habe ich so den eindruck ja ich denke mal ich denke
mal das liegt zum größten teil daran weil sich größere cloud anbieter und hoster so
ein bisschen darauf eingestellt haben weil die auch nicht blöd sind weil die das ganze
auch beobachten und ich meine wenn jetzt auf einmal ein webserver ungefragt terabyte weise
dns traffic bekommt könnte man sich schon überlegen das ist das irgendwie das scheiden
wahrscheinlich war es nicht so ganz zu stimmen oder und ich denke mal das dürften die systeme
bei den cloud anbietern und hoster mittlerweile relativ gut und relativ schnell erkennen natürlich
lassen sie sich das auch ordentlich bezahlen das darf man auch nicht dazu sagen muss man
auch dazu sagen also also ddos protection ist nicht ist nicht ganz billig ja chat ihr
habt recht tcp sessions spam ist auch relativ beliebt tcp sessions spam ist auch relativ
beliebt also da macht man ganz viele tcp anfragen und beantwortet die halt nicht man schickt
die mit gefälschte absender adresse hin lässt die offen und hofft halt dass dann irgendwann
das system verläuft das funktioniert heute auch nicht mehr wirklich so gut weil es ist
halt alles besser geworden also netzwerkgeräte sind besser geworden server software ist besser
geworden beispielsweise werden heute einfach tcp verbindungen die nur so halb geöffnet
wurden also wo es so einen sun gegeben hat einfach wieder verwendet und dementsprechend
kriegst du die systeme gar nicht mehr wirklich folgespammt mit 90 tcp sessions es gibt es
gibt jede menge es gibt jede menge sachen zumindest die schutzmaßnahmen lassen sich
die cloud anbieter ordentlich bezahlen keine ahnung was so web application geschichten
kosten aber es ist auf jeden fall nicht billig könnten wir eigentlich gleich mal ausrechnen
wir gucken gleich mal bei google gucken gleich mal bei google in die preistabelle und gucken
wie das was das alles so gekostet hat ja aber so diese klassische sache mit wir machen
einfach nur möglichst viel traffic so hinlos traffic traffic spam das können cloudflare
google microsoft und so eigentlich ganz gut ganz gut händeln mittlerweile also wie gesagt
ich denke in zukunft werden wir mehr solcher sachen sehen und weniger so hirnloses traffic
gespamme nenne ich jetzt mal weil das weil das wahrscheinlich immer weniger zum ziel
führt und die cloud anbieter ja mittlerweile auch wenn wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt
riesen bandbreiten so für spitzenlastzeiten haben also das musst du erstmal voll didosten
das kostet natürlich auch ein bisschen was als angreifer also so einfach ist das nicht
glücklicherweise glücklicherweise ist es mittlerweile so dass du dich nicht mal als angreifer drauf
verlassen muss dass es irgendwie einen botnetz aus allen verseuchten viren verseuchten desktop
systeme gibt glücklicherweise sind wir im iot zeitalter angelangt das heißt an solchen
didos attakten können sich heute natürlich auch glühbirnenautos kühlschränke smartphones
veraltete netzwerkgeräte und klos beteiligen also es sind nicht mehr nur alte desktop rechner
mittlerweile sind wir weiter mittlerweile kann die glühbirne mit didosten also zumindest
muss man halt sagen der unterschied zwischen dem natürliche klo kann auch didosten klo
im wlan alte firmware irgendwas das kann alles passieren ich würde es nicht wundern
wenn an solchen didos angriffen nicht auch mittlerweile smarte klos beteiligt waren und
smarte toaster und smarte kühlschränke und autos und alles mögliche kannst du alles
mittlerweile knicken zum größten teil werden es natürlich immer noch desktop pc sein ungesicherte
netzwerkgeräte nicht geupdatete smartphones und sowas aber dass dein toaster an irgendeinem
microsoft didos beteiligt war ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich im jahr 2022 das kommt
ja isa das kommt noch dabei im iot bereich gerade die china chinesen hersteller die juckt
das zum größten teil mal gar nicht ob ihr zeug gepatcht ist oder ob das überhaupt von
haus aus sicher ist und gerade bei iot geräten die halt rein über die cloud gesteuert werden
permanent eine verbindung haben also den dingern trau ich ja prinzipiell nicht über den weg
deswegen habe ich auch ein eigenes wlan eigenes wlan wo das alles reinkommt die nirgends
wohin dürfen wenn ich es nicht flashen kann und selbst die geflashten sache kommen da
rein ja was wollte ich jetzt sagen aber wie gesagt hier ging es ja nicht um reinen um
reinen traffic spam sondern hier ging es um layer 7 didos also sprich wahrscheinlich
war den angreifern hier bei dieser google geschichte auch klar ja hier los traffic spammen
führt wahrscheinlich nicht zum gewünschten ziel und bei dem angriff waren das requests
über https und requests über https sind natürlich für beide seiten schwieriger das
ist mehr aufwand beim beim angreifer immerhin muss https verbindung machen muss tls handshakes
machen alles mögliche dass du deine requests schicken kannst es ist natürlich auch schwieriger
zu erkennen so einen so einen gerade über https layer 7 didos natürlich auch schwieriger
zu erkennen das liegt zuerst mal daran also was ist denn das hier warum kann ich meine
emotes nicht richtig anzeigen ja das das liegt das liegt zum als liegt einmal daran dass
jetzt hier der angreifer seine absender ip nicht mehr fälschen kann weil wenn du https
aufbauen willst dann musst du in den tls https handshake machen und den kannst du nicht
machen wenn deine absender ip gefälscht ist weil du kriegst dann die antwort nicht mehr
und zum handshake machen brauchst du halt allein schon für die tcp verbindung brauchst
halt eine gültige absender ip das heißt wenn du sowas hier machen willst dann brauchst
du eine gültige absender ip das heißt irgendwie massig gefälschte pakete abschicken ist da
nicht das macht es natürlich dann auch zum erkennen wieder schwieriger weil es sind
halt so legit ip adressen die absender was auch normale kunden für den jeweiligen service
sein könnten also das macht es auch schon mal es macht zwar aufwendiger für den angreifer
es macht aber auch aufwendiger für denjenigen das erkennen will den den traffic zu klassifizieren
also sprich kann das jetzt weggeschmissen werden oder nicht ja und außerdem gerade
wenn es https ist in dem fall war es nicht so ich sage es jetzt aber trotzdem weil normalerweise
gerade wenn es https ist kann dein cloud anbieter mit dem traffic ja eh schon mal nichts anfangen
weil echter traffic und dedos traffic ja über https verschlüsselt die request über https
gehen zu deinem system ja komplett gleich aussehen das sind einfach ganz normale https
verbindungen die dann cloud anbieter nicht mitlesen kann und da auch keine magic analysen
machen kann ist das jetzt vielleicht den dedos angriff ist das vielleicht ein echter user
request kann es nicht also normalerweise kann ein cloud anbieter nicht reingucken weil dein
server und der client reden über https miteinander in der mitte sieht das keiner das ist ja grad
das sinn von https in dem fall ist es nicht so weil wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an in
dem fall ist es nicht so der header ist nicht unverschlüsselt ach so warte mal bin ich
mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher initial könnte sein am ende ist es ja eine tls ist es ja
auf tcp eben eine tls verbindung bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher ist der hat mir das nicht
mal ausprobiert nee den header siehst du auch nicht oder siehst nee du siehst den header
aber halt bei https nicht du machst du machst ein tls handshake mir ist aus dem kopf gar
nicht so sicher was du siehst und was du nicht siehst keine ahnung weiß ich aus dem kopf
nicht zumindest in dem fall ist es eh egal in dem fall ist es eh egal weil anscheinend
derjenige der bei diesem dedos angriff angegriffen wurde also wurde ja nicht google direkt angegriffen
sondern es wurde jemand angegriffen der den cloud service von google ehrlich gesagt ich
weiß es grad aus dem kopf nicht was du siehst und was du nicht siehst zumindest es wurde
ja jemand angegriffen den cloud service von google verwendet und was der gemacht hat ist
der hat einen google https load balancer verwendet das heißt der macht tls terminierung auf
google seite ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich das so geil finde ehrlich gesagt aber das sorgt
dafür dass google auf jeden fall in den request reingucken kann ob man das jetzt haben will
naja ich weiß nicht ehrlich gesagt aber in dem fall in dem fall ist es so also der anbieter
hat sich dafür entschieden er will tls terminierung bei google machen dementsprechend kann google
in den traffic reingucken was ihm wohl jetzt auch was gebracht hat dass google in den traffic
reingucken kann weil dementsprechend hat google relativ schnell erkannt dass diese requests
verdächtig aussehen und rein von der theorie her muss man ja sagen ein gut gemachter http
request kann schon ziemlich viel traffic verursachen und last erzeugen auf den systemen denen
die request schickt ich meine zum beispiel überlegt euch mal ihr seid ein angreifer und
schickt einen login request an einen service überlegt euch mal was an diesem login request
alles dran hängt also erstmal muss natürlich in tls https handshake gemacht werden dass
die verbindung funktioniert in dem fall passiert das auch ein proxy davor ok aber damit damit
der service überhaupt checken kann ob ihr euch einloggen könnt oder nicht muss er
eine datenbank muss er eine datenbank abfrage machen also sprich gibt es den user überhaupt
mit dem ihr euch versucht einzuloggen stimmt das password und dann muss er eine fehlermeldung
generieren euch zurückschicken das heißt mit einem einfachen für euch in anfangen
relativ einfachem login request verursacht ihr auf mehreren eben jede menge traffic und
jede menge last auf dem service oder auf den system oder auf dem einzelnen server je nach
dem wie die architektur aussieht also ein einfacher login request für euch ist relativ
easy aber die antwort was das an traffic brauchen was das an ressourcen braucht um die antwort
darauf zu generieren ist relativ hoch und jetzt überlegt euch mal ihr spamt solche
login requests 46 millionen mal pro sekunde da geht schon ein bisschen was das das macht
nicht nur das macht nicht nur massig traffic das macht vor allem auch last und hat einfluss
auf die auf die server kapazitäten also sprich kann durchaus sein dass die server bei dem
dass dies dass das in irgendwie dass die anwendung crash das zu viel ram brauche dass die log
files die plade voll machen oder oder was auch immer also sprich das schlägt tatsächlich
mehr durch so ein angriff wie das hier reine traffic spammen was wo microsoft drüber geschrieben
hat und hier sind es halt 340 pakete einfach so stumpfe udp pakete die sekunde und hier
sind halt 46 echte requests die auch wirklich last verursachen und auch wirklich was machen
oder wirklich beantwortet werden müssen und wenn der der wenn er das 46 millionen mal die
sekunde macht dann ist das schon ein bisschen was es ist dann natürlich auch für den angreifer
aufwendiger so was zu machen das hier ist relativ relativ easy das hier ist dann auch
für den angreifer schon ein bisschen aufwendiger bisschen kostenintensiver ist aber auch einschneidender
für den in angegriffen wird in dem fall wie gesagt zumal mittlerweile du ja auch auf
iot geräte für solche angriffe zurückgreifen kannst ja von klübirn bis autos bis klos
und alles mögliche oder oder mikrotik router wurden beispielsweise die letzten jahre über
ganz gerne mal mit veralteter firmware übernommen und gerade die hängen an der position wo
sie auch ordentlich bandbreite haben also da geht da geht schon ein bisschen was naja
zumindest um das jetzt mal abzuschließen google sagt natürlich sie haben das ganze relativ
schnell bemerkt und natürlich auch nur weil die ihren htps load balancer verwendet haben
und der kunde hat irgendwie cloud adaptive armor protection verwendet und die haben gleich
am anfang als die dedos anfragen angefangen haben haben sie das erkannt und haben dem
kunden empfohlen sie dass er soll doch er soll doch irgendwie da so eine application
level firewall regel einschalten und dann war gut der angriff ging übrigens genau 69
minutes also wenn das nicht der miem angriff schlechthin ist dann weiß ich auch nicht
corona scheint auch nicht ganz vorbei zu sein ja und in dem fall ging das ganze halt auch
nur oder konnte google das auch nur so easy erkennen weil eben ein google htps load balancer
verwundet wurde also sprich google konnte da reingucken da bin ich jetzt persönlich
kein so großer fan von aber gut was solls dort haben sie das dann erkannt das war es
nicht stimmt dann haben sie ihre regel aktiviert dass das ganze getrosselt wird die haben das
irgendwie rate limit steht da glaube ich drin limit limit ja sie haben das rate limited
dass sie nicht so viele reguläre kunden betrifft die das vielleicht die vielleicht ja legit
anfragen stellen die so ähnlich aussehen dann lief die attacke 16 69 minutes und dann
war wieder gut weil sie interessant fand wo der angriff her kam das sind natürlich die
üblichen verdächtigen wieder brasilien russland indien idee weiß ich nicht was ist denn idee
indonesien das passt ja indonesien ja indonesien wird sein ja ja indonesien passt auch bei
sowas die sind da die die indonesien indoneser die sind da auch bei sowas immer immer gut
vorne mit dabei wenn sowas angeht ja genau also sprich es waren am ende irgendwie 5000
noch was ips beteiligt in 5200 oder so nee 5.2 also von 5256 source ips über 132 länder
wie gesagt topländer waren halt die üblichen verdächtigen die sind da immer ganz gerne
dabei und google sagt hier auch zum vergleich dass man so als noob mal ein bisschen das
einschätzen kann wie groß das ist die sagen also das zehn sekunden dieses angriffs sind
ungefähr das was wikipedia täglich insgesamt an einem tag für requests bekommt und wikipedia
ist halt eines der top 10 seiten in der welt was traffic angeht also sprich der angriff
hatte in zehn sekunden das antreff oder das an requests gemacht was wikipedia in einem
tag bekommt das ist halt schon ein bisschen was das ist halt da brummt da brummt schon
ein bisschen kann ich kann ich nachvollziehen jetzt müssen wir noch mal gucken was das
ganze gekostet hat das wird mich nämlich mal tatsächlich interessieren google cloud armor
heißt der graben pricing gucken wir mal ja von terrabits steht da nix microsoft lässt
sich ja hier sehr ausführlich über bandbreite aus hier steht nix über bandbreite drüber
hier gibt es zum größten teil um requests und wie geil google ist und das ganze abgewert
hat das hat mich tatsächlich auch mal interessiert ich meine die bandbreite ist jetzt in dem
fall wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so entscheidend gewesen weil sie hauptsächlich darum gegen
möglichst viel last aber natürlich auch traffic zu generieren aber ja der restliche
teil ist im prinzipie einfach nur wie geil google ist also bisschen bisschen lobe eigene
lobpreisung auf google so schauen wir mal was der graben kostet ich weiß wir wissen
es natürlich nicht was die für einen vertrag mit google haben ob die das hier jetzt bezahlen
oder nicht so web application firewall hier 75 cent pro millionen anfang also das heißt
0,75 mal 46 dann haben wir das ganze pro sekunde also 34 dollar sagen wir euro scheiß auf
dollar und das mache ich kein grotes unterschied 34 euro pro sekunde hat das gekostet ja da
muss man sich ja langsam fragen ist der ausfall nicht vielleicht billiger ok und das ganze
jetzt mal 69 weil es hat halt 69 minuten ne moment das stimmt irgendwas nicht habe ich
irgendwas habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht ach mal 60 sekunden habe ich vergessen wollte
ich kann das ist deutlich zu wenig dachte ich mir das ist deutlich zu wenig mal 60 muss
er also 0,75 mal 46 in der sekunde mal 60 in der minute mal 69 für die für die gesamte
laufzeit ok also das hat die ungefähr 150.000 euro gekostet diese dedos protection wahrscheinlich
je nach vertrag mehr oder weniger ja das euro oder dollar ist macht jetzt auch nicht fett
ich tippe drauf dass wenn der service down gewesen wäre es teurer gewesen ist weil wer
so einen aufwand hat und sowas bereit ist zu machen und zu bezahlen der hat wahrscheinlich
einen service dahinter der wichtig ist aber trotzdem also wenn ihr einfach nur ein kleiner
kackladen seid der mal von irgendwo gededost wird wahrscheinlich ist die dedos protection
teurer als dass ihr mal kurz ne stunde weg seid aber natürlich muss man sagen ein kleiner
kackladen wird auch nicht so nen riesen dedos abkommen weil das ist ja auch nicht umsonst
sowas zu machen es kostet ja auch was es kostet den angreifer ja auch was also insofern
der ist wahrscheinlich relativ relativ safe und was man halt auch nicht vergessen darf
diese ganzen posts hier sei es jetzt von sei es von microsoft oder google oder cloudflare
ja die sich ja alle überschneiden immer über über über treffen mit größtem dedos
aller zeiten und sowas abgewehrt ein bisschen werbung ist das natürlich auch das ist 50
prozent immer werbung das heißt die freuen sich eigentlich drüber wenn mal wieder irgendeiner
groß gededost wird das können sie dann schon abwehren und dann können sie wieder einen
blog post rausbringen und sagen wir sind der geilste anbieter überhaupt und haben es total
krass drauf das war ein 69 minuten lang 46 millionen anfragen pro sekunde achso ja glaub
schon na am anfang war es ein bisschen weniger der peak der peak war 96 millionen nee das
war weniger es war weniger es war 46 millionen war eigentlich bloß ne minute oder so also
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich hat sich sogar ein bisschen weniger gekostet aber rechnen
wir rechnen wir mit 150.000 was vor 20 anfragen wo steht da was also immer hätte sein können
war es ja nicht aber ja das hätte eigentlich 420 sein müssen dann hätte es richtig gepasst
es war weniger aber mein aber so haben wir ein oberes ende ausgerechnet 150.000 150.000
euro hat es denn im oberen gekostet wahrscheinlich hat es nur die hälfte gekostet wenn man sich
das hier anguckt ja das macht nichts wenn das nicht versteht trotzdem fand ich fand ich
ganz interessant sich mal anzugucken wie gesagt ich denke es wäre auch für den angreifer
nicht ganz billig und wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen frustrierend weil es nicht so
ganz funktioniert hat manchmal habe ich ja das gefühl die dedos in sich selber irgendwie
dass sie neue blog post machen können weil das geld und die infrastruktur dafür hätten
sie aber so weit will ich jetzt mal nicht gehen was sagt er denn ja wahrscheinlich haben
die die plus stufe wir wissen es ja nicht wir haben keine ahnung was die haben wer weiß
was die am ende bezahlen keine ahnung wir wissen es nicht und ich muss euch ganz ehrlich
sagen diese preistabellen sei es jetzt google oder was azure also was microsoft da verzapft
ich blick da nicht durch bei amazon genauso wenig ich blick da nicht durch also ich finde
das weiß nicht wie es wer von euch mit arbeitet und und wem es da vielleicht ähnlich geht
ich finde das unglaublich schwierig durchzublicken was am ende wirklich was kostet wenn du zum
beispiel in azure bei microsoft eine popeliche vm anlegst da kommt so viel dabei und es ist
so viel inklusive und so viel dann auch wieder nicht dass du am ende gar nicht genau es gibt
ja diesen azure calculator wo man das ausrechnen kann und da kommt so viel dabei da kommt vor
vom speicher von der cpu wie red und dann das ganze sein soll teilweise sogar wird sogar
der speicherplatz berechnet den die config kostet zu speichern für deine vm also diese
keine ahnung diese 25 kilobyte die du an config speichern muss dass deine vm geht müssen auch
auf irgendeinen storage account und dieser storage account kostet dann wieder ein paar
cent also es ist sehr sehr undurchsichtig was sich cloud technisch am ende irgendwas kostet
das einzige was ich euch wirklich wärmstens empfehlen kann selbst also vor allem auch
wenn ihr privat mal was ausprobieren wollt oder bei irgendeinem cloud holster cloud dienstleister
laufen lassen wollt macht ein limit in eurem account macht ein limit und setzt das limit
auch realistisch also sprich wenn ihr sagt ich will nur was kleines ausprobieren dann
setzt das limit halt mal auf 200 euro oder so sofern der jeweilige cloud anbieter ordentliche
limitierung hat was ja auch lange zeit nicht so gerne gemacht wurde von cloud anbietern
weil man dann eben über nicht über nacht die 200.000 euro rechnung den leuten schicken
konnte zumindest setzt ein limit wenn es geht unbedingt weil wenn ihr irgendwie scheiße
baut ihr könnt in einer cloud relativ schnell tausende und zehntausende hunderttausende
euro kosten fabrizieren nur mal so als beispiel wo ich letztens ein video darüber gesehen
habe was wirklich leuten passiert ist und wahrscheinlich auch wenn man wenn man den den nachher ist
den den den support anfragen glaubt genau es gibt leute die benutzen beispielsweise
azure functions oder google amazon lambda und wie heißt der krempel bei google google
functions keine ahnung die das also quasi die diese wie nennt sich noch mal ne nicht
function as a service fast ach cloud abkürzung hört auf also die beispiel zwar die halt ausnutzen
dass du in der cloud direkt logik ausführen kannst und ne ne ne saas ist wieder was anderes
saas ist ich blick schon gar nicht mehr durch system as a service ne was ist saas software
es sagt du scheiße fast ist function as a service und ja es ist infrastruktur as a service
zumindest was ich meine ist fast also sprich das was so unter cloud native läuft es ist
wirklich schlimm also ganz ehrlich wer bei diesem ganzen shit das noch aus dem kopf hinkriegt
der ist glaube ich anderweitig hat anderweitig probleme zumindest gibt es leute die schaffen
es beispielsweise so eine asia function versuche ich mal ein bildchen von von diesem editor
zu zeigen letztendlich wahrscheinlich sieht man nur in visual studio code weil die meisten
das darüber machen also keine ahnung wenn hier irgendwie einer so ne asia function programmiert
asia function ist folgendes du programmierst logik ja zum beispiel hello world du willst
einen webservice haben der auf den request hello world antwortet das lässt du dann als
cloud function laufen sagst du einen endpunkt und du brauchst keinen rechner mehr kein server
mehr keine virtuelle maschine mehr kein application server mehr wo dein code läuft sondern der
läuft direkt in der cloud auf einer plattform die dich nicht interessieren muss und wenn
du da jetzt aus versehen zum beispiel einen service hast für login ja du willst dass
ich deine user einloggen können az 900 habe ich gemacht war pains jam war ziemlich vieles
ziemlich vieles powerpoint abgelesen von dem dozent war mega kacke schule also hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen zumindest wenn du jetzt beispielsweise service hast über solche
functions in der cloud wo sich user einloggen können dann müssen diese cloud services ja
sich untereinander aufrufen können also du hast beispielsweise ein login service der
dann unter der haube wieder auf einen anderen service zugreift der dann auf die datenbank
zugreift und guckt ob der user sich einloggen darf so und wenn du da nicht aufpasst und
aus versehen es schaffst dass mehrere funktionen sich gegenseitig aufrufen dann hast du quasi
eine art endlosschleife nur eine endlosschleife mit functions was darauf rausläuft dass du
millionen aufrufe und du bezahlst den kram pro aufruf bzw. pro ja kopierte aufrufe pro
tausende pro zehntausende wie auch immer das dann gestaffel ist aufrufe und dann generierst
du über nacht millionen function aufrufe und am anderen tag guckst du in dein cloud
konto rein und stellst fest ich habe eine halbe million schulden bei google das ist
aber doof und dementsprechend limit auch wenn ihr einfach nur mit rum spielt macht
den limit in euren cloud cloud es gibt genug berichte von dass google das tatsächlich
recht ja auch microsoft amazon und so auch aber dass sie das teilweise relativ kuland
handhaben solche sachen wenn du denen schreibst wir haben hier mist gebaut dass sie dann sagen
ja ok wir lassen euch das aber da würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen also wenn
die klautsachen werden macht den limit rein red jetzt nicht von drei vms in der cloud
sondern welche wenn ihr solche functions und cloud native geschichten und sonst was
verwendet vor allem wenn ihr noch nicht genau wisst was ihr macht macht den limit rein
sofern es der anbieter kann so hätten wir das auch durch ganz schön lang geschwätzt
aber musste auch mal sein dazu könnte ich leute was haltet ihr davon dazu könnte ich
eigentlich ein video heute machen oder zu dieser geschichte und mich quasi das was ich hier
im stream gesagt habe noch mal in etwas überlegterer form ja ich habe die az 900 schulung gemacht
oder ist das das zertifikat und zertifikat habe ich nett ich habe ich habe die ich habe
die schulung gemacht oder training ja also ich habe ich habe insgesamt drei schulung
gemacht ich habe 900 oder 901 oder irgendwie so was gemacht 400 noch was und das andere
war dann 401 und 402 oder irgendwie so was ich weiß es gar nicht mehr die schulung war
aber alle kacke tja musste mal überlegen also die schulung waren alle müll von microsoft
das war ein dozent der powerpoint vorliest aber wenn du die gemacht hast da gibt es doch
immer so test test fragen und labs also wenn du die schulung gemacht hast da hast du zugang
da kriegst du einen account mit glaube ich 100 euro gut haben und du kannst die prüfungsvorbereitung
damit machen also die haben ja dann quasi komplette komplette übung und anleitungen
und und und tests da drinnen ja ansonsten kann ich ja leider auch nicht mehr sagen dozent
der nur vorliest klassiker die sollten das so machen wir haben den auch gefragt können
wir nicht ein bisschen mehr übung machen aber nein microsoft möchte dass die dass
die schulungen so gemacht werden dass die schulungen einheitlich sind also bei hetzner
bin ich mir gar nicht sicher ob du überhaupt ein limit setzen kannst aber bei hetzner ist
das auch kein größeres problem also erstens hetzner hat standardmäßig wenn du es nicht
erweiterst limits was anlegbare objekte angeht also allein schon damit ist ziemlich stark
limitiert was du maximal ausgeben kannst und hetzner hat keine functions hetzner hat
ja im prinzip also hetzner cloud hat ja im prinzip vms load balancer und ein bisschen
firewall regeln wenn auch nicht so advanced und da würde ich mir jetzt wenig gedanken
machen dass du da irgendwie traffic ja und bei hetzner hast du bei ja du kannst dich
benachrichtigen das weiß aber nicht ob dich bei soviel traffic benachrichtigen das weiß
ich gar nicht traffic hast du eh in eine richtung bei hetzner unlimited und ich glaube in die
andere 20 gigabyte oder so es ist auf jeden fall genug in der regel hast du da keine probleme
falls du sowas meinst wie rate limiting für für programme die auf einem server laufen
das hat mit dem limit was ich meine nichts zu tun also ich meine wirklich limit setzen
im management interface vom jeweiligen cloud anbieter dass du nicht mehr ressourcen von
denen anfragen kannst oder dass es das halt blockiert wenn du mehr ressourcen anfragen
willst als ein budget hergibt wenn du rate limiting machen willst für deine programme
dann brauchst du software die auf deinem server läuft die rate limiting macht da gibt es
welche da gibt es zum beispiel wir haben es letztens erst im stream verwendet ich habe
den namen wieder vergessen github linux rate limiting nope nope nope nope wie hießen das
was wir letztens verwendet das haben wir letztens verwendet glaube ich genau ne ohne jammel
feil ohne jammel feil ne ne das haben wir nicht verwendet ich kann es jetzt gar nicht
mehr sagen was wir da letztens verwendet haben verdrängt keine ahnung mehr also das kenne
ich aber das haben wir glaube ich nicht nicht benutzt doch das haben wir haben keine jammel
verwendet ich muss mal kurz gucken das war relativ easy wir haben nämlich die komplette
bandbreite der vm einfach limitiert auf 100 mbit wenn du einzelne programme limitieren
willst dann geht das auch aber das macht es ein bisschen komplizierter ich gucke mal kurz
was muss man für das zertifikat tun wenn du ein zertifikat haben willst dann musst
du die prüfung machen und die azure prüfung sind lustig da musst du dich aufs klo setzen
nur halb kappa weil die haben ziemlich ne traffic ich weiß wirklich nicht mehr was wir da gemacht
haben zum traffic limitieren ich weiß nicht mehr was wir verwendet haben wenn ich den
namen des programs sehe weiß ich wieder sofort wie heißt mein interface ens 33 wandershaper
wandershaper haben wir verwendet genau gitarre wandershaper jetzt jetzt weiß ich wieder
wandershaper haben wir verwendet da kannst du nämlich zum beispiel sagen ich möchte
dass mein interface bloß noch 40 mbit im download hat und sowas das geht dann das geht
aber fürs komplette interface nicht pro anwendung pro anwendung gibt es auch software aber das
haben wir in dem fall nicht gebraucht ja aber noch mal eine sache zu den microsoft prüfung
die sind relativ streng was die prüfung angeht also du musst dich filmen per webcam ich weiß
nicht ich kenne es nur vom hören sagen vielleicht chat vielleicht hat jemand von euch schon
mal solche microsoft prüfung gemacht der das ein bisschen genauer sagen kann also das
was ich gesehen habe was ich gehört habe ist du musst dich filmen bei den prüfungen du
musst den raum abfilmen bei den prüfungen du brauchst permanente kamera auf dich oder
aufs auf den bildschirm oder auf die tastatur vielleicht auch sogar mehrere kameras es darf
niemand durchs bild laufen du darfst dich nicht umdrehen du darfst keine die tür öffnen
also es darf nichts passieren also alles was nur den anschein eines bescheissens sein könnte
fliet das ist das ist schlimmer als die fans ja ist echt so und also kannst du komplett
kannst du ziemlich ziemlich heftige anforderungen an die prüfung aber ich meine okay die wollen
halt auch nicht dass jeder da bescheißt wenn du dich nur räusperst wirst du ermahnt ja
könnte ja sein dass du per räuspern kommunizierst mit irgendeinem typ der vor der tür steht
ihr dann zettel durchschiebt oder so oder du hast was du hast du hast was versteckt also
ich gehe davon aus die leute bescheißen dabei halt auch wirklich und dementsprechend sind
die da so allergisch dagegen
ja ich finde man muss es nicht übertreiben microservice ist nur um microservice ich muss
jetzt einfach noch mal sagen also cloud zeug machen um das cloud zeug willens oder microsoft
service ist einfach weil microsoft microservice einfach weil microservice jetzt cool und angesagt
sind hat ja keinen sinn das ganze kommt in der regel erst richtig zur geltung wenn man
irgendein service hat der skalieren muss ihr wisst ja wir skalieren weder horizontal noch
vertikal wir skalieren gleich diagonal also sprich wenn ihr irgendein service habt oder
irgendein dienst anbietet der skalieren muss in der regel sind das halt services die mal
extrem viel und mal relativ normal und wenig benutzt werden also stellt euch jetzt mal zum
beispiel vor stellt euch jetzt mal zum beispiel vor ihr habt service xy gebaut und auf einmal
macht pewdiepie ein video über eure webseite dann müsst ihr skalieren und wenn ihr das
im vorfeld für diesen fall natürlich schon ausgelegt habt in der cloud mit microservice
dann könnt ihr richtig krass skalieren von zwei usern auf zwei millionen allerdings wäre
das nur ja ziemlich bescheuert so zu ingenieren weil ich würde nicht auf den fall hoffen
dass pewdiepie ein video über euren service macht und der aufwand eine webseite zu entwickeln
oder web service zu entwickeln wo das backend auf einer vm läuft und sagen wir mal für
5000 user ausreicht ist halt einfacher als in den web service zu entwickeln der sich
über 500 microservices erstreckt der sich da zwar richtig krass skalieren lässt aber
keine sau mehr versteht was da eigentlich passiert also ich bin da mein so was muss mit
bedacht eingesetzt werden ja und vieles sich auch über die zeit so ein bisschen entwickeln
die sparkasse will fünf cent pro pusch benachrichtigung haben tja sparkasse sagt eh also ich habe
zwei konten ich habe eins bei der sparkasse und eins bei der direktbank eins für business
stonks zeug also und und noch eins für stonks übrigens über 1000 euro plus diesen monat
1600 euro plus diesen monat die stonks stonks gehen richtig steil gerade ja und wie gesagt
ich habe ich habe das konto für die stonks ich habe das konto für für business und ich
habe das mein privates konto und die sparkasse geht mir mit abstand am meisten auf den sack
die sparkasse möchte mir auch laufen irgendwelche beratertermine und so was aufschwätzen so
nach dem motto haben sie schon versucht ihr xy zu optimieren haben sie schon gesagt leute
geht mir nicht auf den sack lass mich einfach in ruhe ja das geht auch wonder shaper ist
quasi ein frontend für irgendwelche low level tools also cisco zertifikate ich habe ich
habe ja mal vor uhrzeiten in cc na gemacht cc na das muss man das erwähne ich normalerweise
nicht weil cc na die hat ja jeder eigentlich irgendwann mal zumindest die die schulung
zu gemacht mittlerweile ist es auch schon expired zumindest damals war die prüfung halt noch
vor ort und da musstest du wirklich in den prüfungen da stand da hatte es so ein so ein
typ so so zwei zertifizierte cisco typen oder hat es so eine aufgabe so nach dem motto richten
sie jetzt keine ahnung irgendein interconnect zwischen zwei switchen mit vilans xy wie auch
immer ein trank port heißt ja trank port heißt es ja bei cisco zwischen zwei switches
ein und sorgen sie da dafür hast du das gebaut und da kam da wirklich dieser dude an und
hat das kontrolliert ob das funktioniert und was du was du konsolentechnisch eingegeben
hast also das war auch vor ort gar nicht ohne im prinzip ist der cc na inhalt relativ easy
aber wenn du es aus dem kopf komplett alles wissen muss ohne nachzugucken und wenn du
den prüfer typ hast der sich wirklich alles genau anguckt was du machst sind auch einfache
sachen relativ kompliziert spending tree ist aber wieder was anderes spending tree ist dass
du keine schleifen in deinem geswitcher hast und trank port ist ein port wo mehrere zumindest
bei disco wo mehrere vilans drüber gehen
was ist die frage gewesen kennst du eine gute alternative günstige alternative zum raspberry
pie tja im prinzip das war stripes gesagt hat was du machen willst ansonsten zum raspberry
pie selber gibt es keine gute alternative du hast zwar jede menge mittlerweile du kannst
der sbc kannst du suchen ja single board computer oder suchst du ein raspberry pie alternative
es gibt jede menge single board computer alternativen zum beispiel auch die otroid otroid sachen
die sind ganz gut habe ich auch ein paar von aber das sind alles keine wirklichen alternativen
zum raspberry pie weil den raspberry pie machen mehrere dinge aus erstens der preis
der bisher eigentlich relativ günstig war mittlerweile unglaublich dämlich teuer aber
preislich war raspberry pie immer ziemlich gut und das zweite der mega vorteil beim raspberry
pie ist die software unterstützung und vor allem die riesen auswahl an tutorials und
videos und hilfen und projekte und und zusatzbord hat das gesamte raspberry pie ökosystem
das hast du bei keiner anderen plattform also bei keiner single board computer plattform
bei keiner anderen single board computer plattform als beim raspberry pie in diesem umfang das
heißt es gibt keine gute alternative zum raspberry pie in diesem umfeld so die otroid
dinger gehen auch aber du wirst feststellen dass support wie gut das wie easy das unterdienungs
zu machen ist dort etwas komplizierter und du musst auch einiges selbst wissen und machen
dass es damit geht ich hatte lange zeit ein otroid hc 2 im einsatz das ist so ein ganz
kleines bord gewesen mit wo man eine festplatte anschließen konnte also sprich das ist quasi
ein riesen passiv kühlrahmen und ein kleines bord mit sata anschluss und da hatte ich mein
tv headend server drauf laufen tv headend ist was wo man mit einem dvbc stick mit dem
dvbc tuner fernseh empfangen kann und aufnehmen kann und und serienaufnahmen machen kann so
was hatte ich quasi fernsehaufnahmen drüber laufen da hatte ich eine 2 terabyte ssd später
dran und habe das da drüber gemacht aber und das haben wir glaube ich sogar im archiv
das haben wir damals sogar irgendwo im vor drei jahren haben wir das gemacht im stream
ja ja max ist gut und damit der dvbc stick und das jeweilige betriebssystem mit dem treiber
für den dvbc stick darauf gelaufen ist mussten wir einen eigenen kernel kompilieren damals
mit ich weiß gar nicht wie wir es gemacht haben irgendwo hier irgendwo immer kernel
kompiliert und dann haben wir glaube ich noch tv headend kompiliert das ist was das problem
hast du unterm respire hier läufts guckt das problem hast du unterm raspberry pi nicht
weil unterm raspberry pi installierst du das einfach gut ist und raspberry pi das os ist
auch relativ aktuell auf debian basiert also die kombination aus einfachheit halber normalerweise
früher den preis und der gar nicht schlechten hardware war machte macht das einzigartig
den raspberry pi also gibt es eigentlich keine gute alternative äh ne ne ne den den den
den tv headend haben wir noch mal zusätzlich auf einer hetzenerkiste kompiliert mit 48
kern ja das war aber für meine neue linux box für den odroid haben wir das damals glaub
sogar auf dem odroid selber gemacht oder so tja also keine alternative für den raspberry
pi was du machen kannst ist je nachdem was du machen willst kannst du gucken ob es beispielsweise
ein normales x86 board tut ja zum beispiel die ähm diese boards ähm wie heißt der solche
dinger hier zum beispiel wobei man da halt echt mal gucken ich weiß nicht ob das ob
das noch aktuell ist solche boards sind auch ganz gut die kosten nicht viel falls es das
noch gibt alter ich habe damals was haben leute wir haben im stream geguckt was habe
ich damals für bezahlt 55 euro oder so was ist denn da los vielleicht sind es auch nicht
mehr die aktuellen ah das sind auch glaube ich gar nicht mehr die aktuellen ok also nach
solchen boards kannst du zum beispiel auch mal gucken die sind relativ stromsparend die
verbrauchen eidl ungefähr so viel wie ein raspberry pi unter naja wie ein raspberry
pi 3 unter volllast also raspberry 3 oder ja so raspberry pi 4 unter volllast braucht
wahrscheinlich eher so 13 14 watt und das board braucht eidl ungefähr 8 also sagen
wir mal ein raspberry pi unter volllast braucht ungefähr so viel wie es gibt keinen sockel
die cpu ist aufgelötet bei diesen boards also dieses board braucht eidl ungefähr so
viel wie der raspberry pi unter volllast also irgendwas zwischen 8 und 10 watt allerdings
muss ich sagen der preis hat es echt in sich mittlerweile ah ja das ist schon besser ab
75 euro da kann man sich das überlegen dafür hast du halt auch mehr rechenleistung du hast
ein x86 dualcore das heißt du hast keinerlei probleme dort irgendwas zum laufen zu bekommen
du kannst ganz normales ok auch mit kleineren ram riegel aber du kannst ganz normales ram
riegel drauf machen das ist auch das ist auch eine option so was hier das ist board und
cpu in einem für 75 euro rechenleistung mehr als der raspberry pi verbrauchen bisschen
mehr natürlich bei weitem nicht so kompakt du brauchst auch ein netzteil du brauchst
theoretisch noch irgendwelche platten dafür hast du halt auch mehr erweiterungsmöglichkeiten
also sprich du kannst halt auch mal eine pc express karte reinstecken und so was du beim
raspberry pi eben nicht machen kannst muss ich mal gucken ist eventuell eine alternative
zu dem was du machen willst möchtest du dir beispielsweise ein netzwerk storage bauen
was ja ganz viele leute lustigerweise im raspberry pi machen wollen wofür der raspberry pi
meiner ansicht nach überhaupt nicht geeignet ist auch der raspberry pi 4 ist also raspberry
pi auch der vierer ist ein ziemlich grottenschlechtes nass und es gibt leute die wollen das trotzdem
an da ist so eine plattform deutlich besser du hast die möglichkeit hier eine karte rein
zu machen für weitere sata anschlüsse du kannst in zehn gigabit netzwerkarte rein
machen wenn auch nicht mit voller power weil du siehst der pc express steckplatz ich weiß
ich ob ihr das erkennt sieht man das leute der pc express steckplatz der ist bloß mal
zwei angebunden oder ist das mal vier ist das mal zwei ist das pc express zwei oder
vier ich guck mal doch mal mal zwei also es ist ein sechzehner slot dass die platt dass
die dass die karte hält aber es ist nur ein pc express mal zwei also sprich ihr könnt
euch eine zehn gigabit netzwerkarte kaufen die wird dann wahrscheinlich bloß mit sechs
sieben gigabit funktionieren in in dem slot zumal es auch nur pc express zwei ist was
auch noch mal langsam ist also für einen zehn gigabit nass ist das auch wenn ich mir
sowas damals damit gebaut habe jetzt nicht das allergeilste es gibt natürlich auch die
möglichkeiten sowas über usb zu machen aber wie gesagt flexibler als schneller flexibler
und besser erweitern also es ist auf jeden fall ist es aber halt auch größer kostet
unterm strich mehr gerade mit den ganzen sachen dabei musste musste dir mal überlegen ob
das nicht vielleicht was sind genau das war stripes gesagt low power internet plattform
du kannst in eine vierfach gigabit karte ohne problem in den zweifach pc express rein machen
dann läuft ja nicht mit kompletter bandbreite das geht das ist kein ding
der barry bayes club das stimmt beim barry bayes club habe ich mich letztens versucht
im stream fake zu registrieren und die haben erkannt dass es eine fake registrierung ist
und haben mich nicht in den club reingelassen
ich finde nicht dass kodi gut läuft auf dem raspberry pi kodi läuft nur gut auf dem raspberry
pi wenn man es noch nie auf einem schild tv oder android tv mit ordentlicher gpu cpu gesehen
hat kodi und generell die oberfläche ist so weich auf dem aktuellen android tv und so
ruckelig auf dem raspberry pi
es ist es ist es läuft benutztbar ja nicht so als dass man sich benutzen könnte aber
es ist nicht nicht schön
so gucken wir uns mal ein bisschen was an was haben wir denn hier windows 11 top 5 features
und wichtige neuere oh oh oh microsoft wobei das video hatte ich irgendwo doch schon mal
auf microsoft huge änderungen
da bin ich mal gespannt
kann man jetzt kann man jetzt in in der tasse ist windows 11 bin ja noch windows 10 kann
man jetzt in der taskleiste
wenigstens ordentlich die programme entgruppieren das wäre eine sache die ich ganz sinnvoll
finden würde aber wahrscheinlich nicht
stuhl morga dankeschön für den sub gucken wir uns mal an gucken wir uns mal an die massive
huge änderungen die microsoft bringt
große update für windows 11 heißt 22 h2 und ist entsprechend für das zweite halbjahr
2022 vorgesehen genauer gesagt sollte es im herbst dieses jahres erscheinen bevor das
update dabei erscheint sehen wir uns heute die fünf wichtigsten features an damit ihr
die neuerungen die
denn da bin ich gespannt aber eine nachricht von unserem heutigen videosponsor text blaze
text blaze ist eine super praktische erweiterung für google ich muss unbedingt auch mehr sponsoring
machen
mittlerweile ist es standard jeder jeder hat sponsoring vor seinen videos nur ich nicht
und es ist ja nicht mal dass ich keine anfragen habe die meisten sachen finde ich aber so
bescheuert für die habe ich keinen bock werbung zu machen
aber mein why not
womit ihr shortcuts für jede art von texten erstellen könnte doch hetzner ads mache
ich ich wollte erst mal warten bis mein corona scheiß richtig vorbei ist dann machen wir
demnächst ein sponsor stream wieder
über das neue dynamische ip feature von hetzner
hier häufig ein dieselbe nachricht schreibt könnt ihr den prozess mit text blaze einfach
ich lasse die werbung aber jetzt trotzdem laufen ich weil wir gucken uns den content
von ihnen an also sind wir mal so nett
seit ich text blaze kenne habe ich unmengen an zeit gespart in dem ich auf linkedin und
den emails ganz schnell auf häufig ähnliche anfragen antworten kann
ladet euch die text blaze chrome erweiterung direkt herunter und sichert euch einen kostenlosen
monat mit der pro version über mein link unten in der video beschreibung
was was läuft dann eigentlich in den s7 p
meinst du die samsung smartphones oder was ist ein s7
oder was ich verstehe es jetzt gerade nicht was sind was sind s7 p l c s
keine ahnung ich weiß doch nicht mal was das ist
was ist das chat was ist das
kann man danach suchen
telefonanlage
keine ahnung habe ich noch nie was mit dazu tun gehabt wo soll ich das wissen keine ahnung
industrieanlagen streuen kein schimmer keine ahnung was da läuft
weiß ich doch nicht
keine ahnung
ich wusste ja nicht mal was ist was das überhaupt sein soll bis eben
der windows explorer wird mit dem kommenden update groß erneuert
übrigens
und bekommt gleich
wisst ihr was ich witzig finde jetzt wo ich das wo ich wo ich wo ich wo ich den channel
gerade sehe also ich hab letztens also ich als linux fan ja
hab letztens ein video gemacht
warum es für viele leute wahrscheinlich keine gute idee ist auf linux umzusteigen
und die hier als quasi microsoft und windows fans haben ein video zugemacht
zehn gründe warum linux besser ist als finders was ich witzig finde weil das quasi die
entgegengesetzte aussage von so entgegengesetzten leuten kommt also sprich ich bin eigentlich
der linux fanboy doch level capji bateman ich bin eigentlich der linux fanboy der sagt
linux ist nicht für jeden was und er ist wahrscheinlich würde ich sagen eher der windows fanboy und
sagt linux ist porc
mehrere neue funktionen dazu aufzeigen einen neuen design des menus links und einer
das ist neu
ok für mich sieht das aus wie vor das stadt das häuschen ist neu das sieht jetzt ein
bisschen aus wie in den kde eiken
an neuen startseite sind die tabs im windows explorer eine erwünschte was
endlich wirklich das glaube ich nicht
es gibt jetzt wirklich nach zehn jahren tabs tabs im windows explorer haben sie es jetzt
geschafft leute ich wette mit euch irgendwas funktioniert
da nicht richtig irgendwas ist da undurchdacht und kacke
wir können mal die vm aktualisieren ja ja ja wobei das update gibt es noch gar nicht
das update gibt es noch gar nicht
echt wichtige verbesserung ja das stimmt
könnt ihr in einem windows explorer fenster mehrere tabs öffnen und so deutlich schneller
und effizienter durch euer datalysystem navigieren wobei ich sagen muss das öffnen sieht sehr
holprig aus oder guckt euch das mal an
guckt mal habt ihr das gesehen wie das menü hier nach und nach aufbaut und so
hier oben in der titelleiste findet ihr nun ein pluszeichen womit ihr einen neuen tab
öffnet
habt ihr gesehen wie
der macht nochmals
ok ok achtung postchamp aufs plus plus plus plus
ja klick guckt mal er hat geklickt guckt mal seht ihr
wie laggy das aufbaut die cache noch nicht mal die icons richtig
wie laggy das aufbaut ihr könnt davon ausgehen wenn ich das sogar in einem youtube video mit
30 fps so hier links das ist das ist krasses rumgelegge
beim aufgehen
womit ihr einen neuen tab öffnet oder eben eine neue registerkarte wie microsoft das
nennt
wir haben die explorer tabs in einem eigenen video schon im detail vorgestellt also werde
ich euch die detaillierte rundschau jetzt ersparen und wenn ihr diese doch sehen wollt
dann findet ihr sie jetzt hier oben in der infokarte sowie
müssen wir uns glaub ich nicht angucken
wie in der beschreibung
eine neuerung des windows 11 22 h2 updates ist auch die startseite im windows explorer
diese beinhaltet jetzt eurer schnellzugriff ordner sowie die favoriten und zuletzt
ich hab nicht die leerzeile gespammt ich hab doch grad mit punkt und comma navigiert
hab ja noch gesehen
das bringt aber nicht nur positive änderungen so hat microsoft die dieser pc ansicht dafür
deutlich im umfang reduziert
warum
sodass dort tatsächlich nur noch eure
ich will usb sticks an der stelle auch auswerfen können und und zeug und was es da alles nur
sonst noch gibt
wenn das da drüber nicht mehr geht ist doch bescheuert
achso nee moment nur das da fehlt jetzt ja das ist ok dass es da oben nicht drinne ist
das braucht ja kein mensch da oben das ist ok also solang usb sticks und sonstige sachen
da noch ordentlich drinne stehen ist es in ordnung
wer sich jetzt übrigens fragt warum ich so wenig laufwerke bei mir im rechner hab ich
hab mehr laufwerke bei mir im rechner aber die sind verschlüsselt und die werden nur
entschlüsselt wenn ich mich anmelde an meinem anderen main windows account
oh was denn da 3,5 gigabyte free sekunde das ist aber ganz schön wenig da muss ich
mal ein bisschen glaube ich muss ich mal ein bisschen was wegschmeißen wieder oder
bisschen sehr wenig
sodass dort tatsächlich nur noch eure lokalen laufwerke sowie eure netzwerk laufwerke angezeigt
das disk clean up tool ok auf gehts für z thumbnails ok ja mach yes
thumbnails hui das hat sich aber gelohnt
guck mal er verwende hier unten die wetteranzeige benutzt das wirklich seriously jemand ernsthaft
diese wetteranzeige
bekommt ebenfalls einige neue funktionen die allerdings eher noch in die kategorie notwendige
nachbesserung
deine suche geht nicht mehr unter windows elf das ist normal die suche ist nicht dafür
gemacht geht zu zu gehen
gehören und weniger zu den wichtigen innovationen des 22 h 2 updates das startmenü in windows
elf wird aber mit dem update ein stück weit anpassbarer und ihr könnt über die einstellungen
bei personalisierung und dann bei start etwas genauer festlegen wie euer startmenü aussehen
soll
gibt es denn jetzt die möglichkeit endlich mal die programme nicht zu gruppieren
nö immer noch nicht geil aussehen soll ihr könnt nun einstellen ob ihr mehr angeheifte
elemente oder mehr empfehlungen sehen möchtet
nein ich will keine empfehlung ihr sollt einfach zumindest mal funktionsgleichheit herstellen
zu windows 98 das wäre doch schon mal was
habe mich bereits als ziemlicher fan von diesen empfehlungen geoutet weil es meine
diese moment ja das ist in ordnung das hier apps empfehlung sowas finde ich müll
wenn es mir beispielsweise sagt zuletzt zuletzt benutzte dateien und so das ist okay weil
es meine zuletzt verwendeten dokumenten und das ist in ordnung immer direkt im startmenü
an aber dafür erzählt er hier so einen anderen zeug
so muss ich mich nicht immer daran erinnern woran ich zuletzt gearbeitet hatte oder wo
sich dieses dokument gerade
ja es ist ja nicht so als wäre es jetzt irgendwas neues gewesen ja das hat windows 95 schon
angezeigt
verstehe aber dass ganz viele leute keine fans davon sind sodass man die empfehlungen
nun auch stark zurückschrauben kann und dann nur noch eine einzige reihe an empfehlungen
dargestellt wird
dann müsst ihr aber erst mal genügend programme finden und apps um das startmenü damit zu
füllen
viel glück damit bei dem microsoft store
kurz gesagt sei auch dass das windows 11 startmenü bald ordner unterstützt
wenn ihr eine app nun auf eine andere app drauf zieht könnt ihr die
das sind immer so dinge wo ich von ausgegangen bin dass das eigentlich schon immer funktioniert
hat
und jetzt erfahre ich nein anscheinend kann das steuer startmenü keinen und nicht mal
ordner
oh fuck
wie sieht dann wie sieht dann sowas
wie sieht dann sowas hier dann zum beispiel aus
gibt es dann gar nicht mehr oder wie
windia start habe ich normalerweise auch ja
diese in so ganz simplen ordnern zusammenfassen und diesen ordnern auch einen namen geben
das design davon ist wirklich sehr simpel und auch unausgereift
in windows 10 war
wer hätte das gedacht
die ordner wesentlich besser durchdacht und haben deutlich besser zum übrigen design
des startmenüs gepasst
ich persönlich finde es aber schade dass man dieses ganze
verschlimmbessern von irgendwas das ist ja fast wie auf battlefield 2042
als wissen sie nicht wie es geht obwohl sie es eigentlich wissen müssten
auch nicht mehrere apps zusammen aus
der clipchamp
endlich
oder zu endlich meine software von mir mit dabei
ein ordner zusammenfassen und direkt vom startmenü entfernen oder direkt
deinstallieren kann
bei dem ganzen spam den microsoft voll installiert bei windows
ich weiß warum ist instagram facebook tiktok standard mit clipchamp ja das beste
von mir
ist auch bitter notwendig
aber i made this
leute
dann die ganzen apps in die eben microsoft empfehlen möchte
mit windows 11 hat microsoft die snap layouts eingeführt die euch mehrere
vordefinierte möglichkeiten bieten die aktuell geöffneten fenster anzuordnen
die snap layouts zeigen sich bisher nur wenn man über das maximieren icon drüber
fährt doch ab windows 11 22 h 2 werdet ihr diese auch beim ziehen eines fensters sehen
ui
wenn ein fenster an den oberen bildschirm ranzieht wird von oben die snap assist leiste
dargestellt
mit vorschlägen wie ihr eure fenster schnell anheften könnt
warum
warum braucht man das warum kann man nicht also jetzt mal ganz dumme frage ja
warum ist das hier jetzt zu viel das guten
also ich mein warum brauche ich eine vorschau wie mein fenster angeheftet
wird wenn ich denn mein fenster einfach anheften könnte wo ich es will
außerdem ist neu dass ihr die snap layouts nun auch per tasten kombination aufrufen
könnt
ach das ging auch nicht
das ging auch nicht
das zeig euch dann die snap layouts für euer aktuelles fenster an
das ist natürlich sinnvoll dass es per tastatur geht
davon sein solltet könnt ihr die snap layouts übrigens auch über die
einstellungen und das system und dann multitasking deaktivieren
die option heißt im deutschen fenster undocken
und dort könnt ihr genau konfigurieren wie die andock layouts bei euch am
computer funktionieren sollen
der task manager zählt zu den wichtigsten system komponenten in windows
ist das kleine programm doch immer dann der rettungsanker wenn sonst alle stricke
reißen
microsoft hat den task manager nun komplett umgestaltet
und er bekommt neben einem neuen design auch
sieht er so viel anders aus
ja der hat jetzt
der hat jetzt
links so eine navigation bar
aber der inhalt vom task manager ist doch immer noch genau der gleiche
erstmal zum design
die haben da einfach irgendwie den neuen uwp wrapper drumherum gemacht das ist doch alles
oder
die leiste hier links passt auch schon mal gar nicht zu dem rest rechts
auf den ersten blick dass der task manager nun deutlich moderner aussieht
das kleine tabs basierte interface wird ersetzt
durch ein modernes icon basiertes menü auf der linken seite
ich sag euch leute das ist einfach nur ein wrapper
um den alten task manager die haben ja die taskleiste hingemacht
und der rest ist ganz normales oldschool win32 zeug
elemente sind nun außerdem etwas größer
das hier
diese liste das ist wahrscheinlich einfach stinknormales win32
embedded in irgendeinem uwp ding
interface wirkt an sich etwas aufgeräumter
der task manager zeigt nun bei den prozessen eine praktische visualisierung der ressourcen
mit hilfe eurer akzentfarbe an
so seht ihr relativ schnell welche programme gerade die meisten ressourcen eures computers
benötigen
wahnsinn feature
außerdem unterstützt der task manager nun einen dunklen modus welcher auch richtig
fein aussieht
es handelt sich hierbei mehrheitlich um ein redesign des bestehenden programs
aber microsoft hat sich immerhin ein neues feature dafür überlegt
der task manager unterstützt ab windows 11 22 h2 einen effizienz modus
welcher im prozesssetup für programme aktiviert werden kann
das geht entweder direkt über die menüleiste oder eben per rechtsklick
wenn der effizienz modus für ein program aktiviert ist limitiert das system die verfügbaren
ressourcen für diesen prozess
sodass dieses programm so effizient wie möglich ausgeführt wird
gleichzeitig
das heißt das programm bekommt ein weniger cpu zeit auch wenn es die haben will
und dann ruckelts oder wie
also mal angenommen ich hab jetzt den browser der eine website hat die eben relativ cpu intensive
animationsgeschiss und so macht
dann ruckelts
oder wie
ja ok doch das ist tatsächlich ganz sinnig
wenn man software verwendet die unnötig viel leistung braucht
die man aber die jetzt irgendwie die du nicht flüssig brauchst ja wenn du irgendeine kack
programmierte software hast die der meinung ist immer ein cpu kern voll auszulasten
ja dann vielleicht
ok ja warum nicht wobei ich ein bisschen befremdlich finde dass man das über den task manager
macht
ich hätte eher erwartet dass man das über hier drüber macht
guckt also ich hätte beispielsweise erwartet
wo haben wir hier firefox
ja nehmen wir mal hier firefox hier
dass man das hier drüber macht hätte ich eigentlich erwartet ja
dass du das für die für die
für das programm festlegst
ok
ermöglicht dies das andere genutzte programme die verfügbare leistung des systems besser
ausnutzen können mit dem effizienzmodus könnte bestimmte programme selbst gewissermaßen
einfach kalt stellen dabei wird die priorität auf gering geschaltet und das programm läuft
dann vorzugsweise mit den effizientesten kern eures prozessors moderne prozessoren kommen
immer häufiger mit performance und effizienz kern daher und ihr als nutzer könnt in windows
11 bald ein bisschen genauer entscheiden wie diese prozessorkerne genutzt werden
ja ist ok das finde ich in ordnung
startet einfach den task manager und lasst die prozessor am besten nach cpu intensität
absteigend auflisten
ja ist ok
nun sucht euch jene programme aus die für euch weniger wichtig sind und steckt diese
einfach in den effizienzmodus
windows 11 wird darauf in die cpu nutzung dieser programme optimieren was auch positive
auswirkungen auf die akkulaufzeit eures laptops haben kann
die taskleiste von windows 11 ist eine der enttäuschendsten neuerungen des betriebssystems
neuerungen ja kann man so sagen
viele funktionen sind entweder bewusst gestrichen worden
oder schlechter als vorher
aus zeitgründen nicht implementiert
das rechtsclick menü der taskleiste ist in windows 11 so gut wie unbrauchbar aber auch
wichtige funktionen wie die unterstützung für drag and drop war nicht vorhanden
mit windows 11 22h2 liefert microsoft auch hier ein
sag mal sind das pringles im hintergrund ich verstehe nicht genau also unterschiedlich
gefärbte pringles
oder was soll das sein
sieht so aus oder
sieht so aus wie pringles
gedringende nachbesserungen aus
drag and drop funktioniert nun endlich und sofern ihr in der zwischenzeit vergessen habt
wie das funktioniert zeigen wir es euch ganz kurz her
einerseits könnt ihr wieder programme an die taskleiste anheften indem ihr sie vom desktop
oder vom startmenü direkt in
krass
punktionsgleichheit zu windows 3.11 hergestellt ne windows 95 3.11 hat noch keine taskleiste
die taskleiste zieht
unglaublich außerdem könnt ihr endlich wieder dateien mit einem programm aus der taskleiste
öffnen mittels drag and drop
wenn ihr ein pdf dokument zum beispiel mit einem gewissen programm in der taskleiste
öffnen wollt
zieht ihr die gewünschte datei einfach auf das program icon und es wird damit geöffnet
wie das ging jetzt das ging in der zwischenzeit nicht so ziehe ich immer meine videos in vegas
rein
ich mache den ordner auf mit dem mit dem footage und dann ziehe ich das über die taskleiste
in in vegas wie soll ich es sonst machen
so einfach kann es gehen unglaublich dass es microsoft bisher nicht implementiert hatte
windows 11 wurde zum start ohne diese features ausgeliefert obwohl windows 10 sie noch hatte
und jetzt sind sie
der witz ist echt und vor allem so unsinnig die haben eh in windows so viel richtig uralt
shit dabei
aber die
neuen sachen sind dann teilweise schlechter als die alten aber diese alten sachen werden
dann entfernt
aber die alten sachen die einfach nur alt und kacke sind die bleiben drin
und die wichtigsten 5 neuerungen von windows 11 22 h2
ok
schönes video muss ich sagen gut gemacht aber die änderungen also wenn das die größten
änderungen sind dann muss ich in nächster zeit auch nicht update
noch viel genauer darauf eingehen aber ich wollte euch einfach mal eine kurze zusammenfassung
von all dem liefern was bald kommen wird
ich hoffe dass euch das video gefallen hat und wenn ja gebt mir gerne einen daumen rauf
und abonniert unseren kanal für noch mehr tips tricks und tests rund um windows 11 nicht
empfehlenswert ist
ok
1 sekunde fragen es läuft kein update im hintergrund
moment das ist mein eigenes video
ok mein eigenes video gucken wir jetzt nicht
wo ist der level cap gb8 leute
ja wir wissen er sagt great changes ahead
blablabla dann kommen keine great changes und am ende sagt er fragte uns dann ob wir
jetzt denken dass battlefield 2042 damit in einem besseren spot ist
und dann ist das video fertig immer das gleiche
bis soll ich euch mal was sagen realtor das ist kein easter egg das ist kein easter egg
die haben einfach die kiste copy pasted von der neuen map auf kaleidoskop
das ist kein easter egg
die waren einfach zu faul
der macht ja immer noch werbung für diesen komischen männer haarnachwachs scam zeug
die
...suggestiert, dass die Map in einem halbdreifenden Regenboden unter dem Damm gesetzt werden könnte.
Jedoch, eine Antwort auf Temporal's Findings suggeriert, dass wir eine mehr ursprüngliche, flottende Situation sehen könnten.
Diese Image zeigt den Spezialisten McKay, die eine Frau auf dem Rücken eines Autos gerettet hat.
Mit Physik hatten sie es in diesem Video aber auch nicht sonderlich, oder?
...in flottenden Wasser, mit einem Helikopter, und es wurde vor dem Launch des 2042 eröffnet, als Teil der Welt der 2042-Backstory.
Und während die Image nur …
... der Concept Art, vor dem Spiel …
... mit den aktuellen Fällen, gibt es eine starke Möglichkeit, dass es im …
Angel, das ist es wieder …
... Temporal hat gefunden.
Die Gebäude sehen authentisch aus, und haben noch nicht in der Region gesehen.
Temporal hat noch keine Concept Art oder visuelle Content speziell auf dem neuen Map gefunden.
anyone's guess as to what it will be also es gibt news dass es habe ich jetzt richtig verstanden es gibt news dass es keine
news gibt dass es eine neue map gibt über die wir nichts genaues wissen aber es ist sehr
möglich dass wir eine Art Flucht in panama town oder eine hohe Location in der Saison 2 bekommen
das ist ja absolut eine große neue News
die Spielerkarten haben viel Glauben zu seiner Spekulation
die Saison 2-Update ist erwartet in den frühen September
dice will likely reveal more info about Saison 2 on monday during their next development
Wann startet das? Wann?
dice will likely reveal more info about Saison 2-Update in den frühen September
die Saison 2-Update ist erwartet in den frühen September
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern dass mal zu den Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 DLCs
oder sagen wir mal Erweiterungen teilweise im Monat voraus schon Teasermaterial und Maps
und so gesehen hat
das Spiel keiner mehr du meinst Hazard Zone, Hazard Zone ist auch eingestellt dice hat
gesagt die entwickeln das nicht weiter
das Spiel keiner mehr du meinst Hazard Zone, Hazard Zone ist auch eingestellt
das Spiel keiner mehr du meinst Hazard Zone ist auch eingestellt
das Spiel keiner mehr du meinst Hazard Zone
das Spiel keiner mehr du meinst
unrun dead